es interesante porque por supuesto a
pesar de que Argentina desde el inicio
abrió sus puertas a potenciales
refugiados de Ucrania no llegaron tantos
porque ellos pueden irse muy fácilmente
a países europeos cercanos a su
territorio lo que sí han empezado a
llegar cada vez más a partir del inicio
de la guerra sobre todo de la
conscripción del llamado a reservistas
por parte de Vladimir Putin del gobierno
ruso en septiembre de 2022 son familias
rusas familias rusas que Encuentran una
posibilidad de ingreso Argentina Por qué
Porque Argentina no les pide visa es muy
fácil para ellos ingresar sin visa
muchas veces en principio como turistas
y después se encuentran la posibilidad
de quedarse como de diferentes maneras
quiero marcar una cosa importante en
general estas familias que se van porque
estuvimos hablando con con algunas de
estas familias pudimos Tener información
al respecto se van porque no quieren
estar más en Rusia no se sienten cómodos
no se sienten cómodos con la guerra y no
se sienten cómodos con la situación que
se vive al interior del país y por eso
dejan el país y por eso vienen acá otras
opciones a veces que evalúan son Turquía
muchos me comentaban que Turquía era una
posibilidad y al venir acá hay algunas
cosas que se facilitan hablábamos de las
mujeres embarazadas bueno es cierto
muchas son mujeres embarazadas más o
menos desde enero de 2022 a enero 2023
fueron unas 22.000 rusos que llegaron al
país hombres y mujeres más o menos la
mitad mujeres muchos según la
información que nos da migraciones de
dirección Nacional de migraciones en
Argentina muchos ya han dejado el país
quedarían unos 9.000 De esos y de ese
total a 2.400 trámites de radicación se
iniciaron y unos 1.026 por familiar por
tener un familiar argentino ese familiar
puede ser un hijo o una hija que nace en
Argentina Al poco tiempo de llegar de
hecho nosotros en France 24 emitimos un
breve reportaje en el que presentamos
una familia rusa de un hombre y una
mujer que llegaron Desde esa Petersburgo
en enero y hace dos días nació su bebé
Esa bebé es Argentina y al ser Argentina
a los sí es cierto les facilita el
trámite de la residencia en Argentina no
de ciudadanía que esa parte que es un
trámite judicial que va por otra vía No
necesariamente eso pero si la residencia
ya les permite quedarse más fácilmente
son familias que están buscando un Nuevo
Horizonte y salir del país en el que ya
no quieren estar Natalia aparte de todas
estas facilidades que hay de pronto para
estas familias para tener a sus hijos
allí en Argentina y recibir la
residencia de este país suramericano
también hay una conexión histórica
porque no es la primera vez que llegan
ucranianos y rusos a este país en otros
momentos de la historia de estos dos
países europeos han llegado oleadas de
ciudadanos a vivir allí en Argentina un
país que siempre ha recibido con los
brazos abiertos a los migrantes europeos
eso es muy interesante Argentina siempre
ha sido muy abierto a la inmigración
europea en un en una parte muy
importante de su historia también ha
llegado mucha inmigración de países
limítrofes en tiempos más recientes
mucha inmigración venezolana también
colombiana pero es interesante lo que
mencionas por ahí la imagen de de la
inmigración europea Argentina para quien
no es de aquí es la Italiana y la
española Sí por supuesto la más fuerte
pero por ejemplo en fines del siglo 19
principios del 20 una de las principales
emigraciones provenía de Rusia de Rusia
también en la zona de Ucrania un
comentario personal pero quiero
compartir una parte importante de mi
familia viene a principios del siglo XX
por ejemplo de esa zona de Rusia Ucrania
que estaban muy entreveradas en esa
época No necesariamente pertenecía a uno
u otro pero es realmente fueron oleadas
muchísimo muchísimo más grandes incluso
que lo de ahora que muchos prefieren no
llamarlo oleada sino un fenómeno
migratorio porque tampoco las cantidades
son tan grandes Es cierto que en zonas
sobre todo de la ciudad de Buenos Aires
al centro es muy impresionante el número
en algunos parques y plazas de juego
sobre todo que son referencias para la
comunidad de nuevos inmigrantes rusos se
puede ver muy bien en hospitales me
comentaba un amigo médico que por
ejemplo en un hospital que trabaja él en
la maternidad se ven cada vez más
mujeres rusas que están yendo a dar a
luz consultando para dar a luz en
escuelas rusos que están inscribiendo a
sus hijos en la escuela sí sí